so it looks like we're going to learn a
lot more about why bill barr didn't
charge
former president trump with obstruction
of justice judge amy berman jackson has
responded to
a foia lawsuit by crew the citizens for
responsible ethics in washington
by basically saying that the doj more or
less lied to the court about its
reasonings for
not moving forward with obstruction of
justice you may recall that in front of
congress
former attorney general bill barr said
that he decided not to charge former
president trump in consultation with the
office of legal counsel and the
department's lawyers
but according to the court's order
having reviewed the memo in camera
it appears that the doj and bill barr
decided not to charge president trump
first and then backfilled everything
after the fact
and as a result we may actually see the
reasoning and the memo that went into
that decision
the bite administration has 14 days to
decide whether to file an appeal
hopefully they won't so we'll see the
memo
and we won't see them in court